me dan
señoras y señores
esta noche y no tengo palabras para no
tener palabras para hablar del islamismo
político radical que llega hasta el
terrorismo
las palabras esas palabras de los dije y
ese mal ya lo nombre las acciones ya las
decidimos si las llevaremos hasta el
final de manera más dura esta noche no
hablaré de los terroristas de sus
cómplices y de todos los cobardes que
hicieron posible este atentado
no hablaré de aquellos que entregaron su
nombre a los bárbaros no lo merecen
ellos ya ni siquiera tienen nombres
esta noche yo no voy a hablar más de la
unidad indispensable que todos los
franceses y todas las francesas
recientes
es preciosa
y obliga a exprimir a todos los
responsables a expresarse con de manera
justa y también a actuar con exigencia
no
esta noche
de fotos y quiero hablar de su hijo
quiero hablar de su hermano
de ser testigos de aquel a quien amaron
el padre quiero hablar de su colega de
su profesor
porque había tomado la elección de
enseñarle hasta asesinados porque
decidió mostrar a sus éxitos enseñar a
sus alumnos a convertirse en ciudadanos
sin duda a aprender las tareas porque
cumplió para cumplirles con liberty
aprender las libertades para ejercerlas
esta noche quiero hablarles
de ésta miguel para ti
para ti amaba los libros software
el saber más que nada
su apartamento era una biblioteca y sus
mejores regalos libros para aprender y
me amaba los libros para transmitir a
sus alumnos y a sus cercanos y verte el
gusto por la libertad y el conocimiento
después de haber estudiado historia
embrión y de haber pensado en
convertirse en un investigador
tomo este camino ya trazado por ustedes
sus padres
de mul director de escuela ambulante
snow y profesor convirtiéndose en el
límite de investigador en pedagogía como
le gustaba presentar sino procesado y se
convirtió en maestro o sí
no podíamos encontrar un mejor lugar que
la sorbona nuestro lugar del saber
universal desde hace varios siglos lugar
del humanismo de la nación para que la
nación pueda rendirle este homenaje
no amaba compasión y enseñar y lo hizo
tan bien en diferentes escuelas
hasta el de confianza santo novena
los circuitos
todos tenemos en nuestro corazón
y en nuestras memorias el recuerdo de un
profesor que cambió el curso de nuestra
existencia
es el profesor aquel que nos enseñó a
escribir a leer a contar a tener
confianza en nosotros mismos es este
profesor que no solo nos transmitimos a
ver sino que nos abrió un camino a
través de un libro o de una mirada
de un instante pasado sencillas por su
consideración
la miel para ti era de aquellos con
aquellos profesores que uno no olvida de
aquellos apasionados capaces de pasar
noches enteras y hume enseñando las de
la historia de las religiones para
mostrarle a los alumnos
yankel que se cuestionaba sus mil veces
y como en este curso sobre la libertad
de conciencia y expresión que preparaba
desde el mes de julio y el verano pasado
en mula al lado de ustedes
y las dudas que compartía con exigencia
por delicadeza y encarnaba en el fondo
aquel maestro que soñaba en esa carta
que acaba de ser leída
la firmeza unida a la ternura la
grandeza del pensamiento y muestra que
el pensamiento sin saber lo que es la
civilización de aquel que se dio como
tarea dgpyca crear republicanos
vuelven como un eco por estas palabras
para hacer un republicano primer chip
hay que tomar al ser humano
y darle la idea de que hay que pensar
por sí mismo no debe obediencia a nadie
que le corresponde a él buscar la verdad
sino simplemente recibirla ya hecha de
un jefe o de un profesor sea quien sea
de república crear republicanos
7 locumba ese era el combate de san
miguel para ti
y si esta tarea hoy puede parecer
gigantesca sobre todo ahí donde la
violencia la intimidación a veces la
resignación
parece más es más actual y esencial que
nunca y si aquí en francia amamos
nuestra nación su geografía sus paisajes
y su historia su cultura y sus
metamorfosis su espíritu y su corazón
si queremos enseñarla a todos nuestros
sentidos y aquí amamos el proyecto a la
vez terrestre y universal de la
república su orden mes y sus promesas
entonces sí
en cada escuela en cada escuela
secundaria en cada liceo vamos a darle a
los profesores del poder de crear
republicanos en el lugar que les
corresponde
vamos a formarlos vamos a considerar
y nos vamos a proteger y apoyar todo lo
que haga falta en la escuela como
también fuera de la escuela
la presión las presiones el abuso de la
ignorancia
que algunos quisieran instaurar y de
obediencia no tienen ese lugar aquí
es usted
si quisiera que mi vida y mi muerte en
aquel curso sirvan para algo que había
dicho él en algún momento
pero entonces también porque samuel
fue asesinado
por qué
el viernes en la noche 72
la gente simplemente en un absurdo y en
la locura arbitraria
una víctima más crítica del terrorismo
gratuito apretó después de todo y
municipal este propósito no era el
objetivo principal de los islamistas
donsini él simplemente enseñaba
él no era enemigo de su religión él
había elegido el corazón él respetaba a
estos alumnos sin importar sus creencias
se interesaba en la civilización
musulmana
no
tutu con five
al contrario samuel para ti
fue asesinado no justamente por todo eso
porque en carnaval la república que
renace cada día en las salas de clase la
diversidad que se transmite y que se
perpetúen en el colegio san miguel para
ti fue asesinado porque los islamistas
quieren nuestro futuro y saben que con
héroes tranquilos como él y no lo sean
nunca lo tendrán
ellos sepa parecida el l méxico
separan a los no separan a los fieles de
aquellos que no creen sólo conocen los
ciudadanos y él creía en el saber
ellos cultivan de luto el odio por otros
quería simplemente ver la cara descubrir
las riquezas
sanmiguel para ti fue la víctima de una
conspiración
de la tontería de la mentira del
amalgama y del odio por el otro el odio
fundido de lo que profundamente de
manera existencial somos nosotros
y el viernes se convirtió en el rostro
de la república no con voluntad nuestra
voluntad y elitista de enfrentar a los
terroristas de reducir a los islamistas
de vivir como una comunidad de
ciudadanos libres en nuestro país
el rostro de nuestra determinación para
comprender aprender mitos y continuar
enseñando
y de ser libres
porque vamos a continuar siendo
profesores y vamos a defender la
libertad que ustedes enseñan también y
vamos a aportar de alto en laicismo no
vamos a renunciar a las caricaturas a
los dibujos institute incluso si algunos
dan marcha atrás
vamos a ofrecer todas las oportunidades
para que las repúblicas iones y le dé a
toda su juventud sin discriminación
alguna
vamos a continuar profesores con todos
los sismos todos los maestros del país
vamos a enseñar
la historia podemos descubrir la
literatura la música todas las horas del
alma y de la mente vamos a amar con
todas nuestras fuerzas el debate los
argumentos razonables las persuasiones
amables vamos a amar la ciencia y sus
controversias como ustedes vamos a
cultivar la tolerancia vamos a buscar
comprender y comprender cada vez más eso
que quisieran alejar de nosotros
vamos a aprender
sobre el humor la distancia no apeló
vamos a recordar que nuestras libertades
en
o sea no solamente con el fin del odio y
la violencia a través del respeto por
otros
vamos a continuar profesores
y a lo largo de sus vidas
los cientos de jóvenes que ustedes han
formado para ejercer este espíritu
crítico
que ustedes les transmitieron y tal vez
algunos de ellos se convertirán también
en maestros y entonces van a formar
ciudadanos jóvenes a su vez en público
amarán la repubblica harán entender
nuestra nación nuestros valores nuestra
europa
dos encendidos
en una cadena del tiempo que no se
detendrá un instinto vamos a continuar
este combate una línea por la libertad o
la gestión y por la razón
el cual ustedes son el rostro porque se
lo debemos
moscú
porque nos lo debemos a nosotros mismos
porque en francia profesores
y ni las luces no se apagan nunca
y que viva la república
y viva francia